và trận trường nó mối cho và chất tổ tải xuân quen ngang cho xuân quen giọng liệm.
Pây ấy, khi có giảm liệm cho trường ống đầy thì nước này,
a dùng không chàng xuân quen ngống đầy này có một tự trường.
Bình chất cơ bản của tự trường nó tác dụng nâng tự lên giang liệm hoặc là lên nâng chân.
Pây ấy là dùng một cái tí văm chân để thử.
Bánh cái tí văm chân này, nó phải nằm trên lường,
xức tự, bỏ chêu lươi theo châu, nâng phát bảo nâng,
phát để xác tí vương của hợp.
Lường xức tự trải chân quen giang liệm hoặc là phải đầy.
Bánh bản đầy phải xác trong chêu tự cộng tay đến vỏng tay như chêu bử rồng mẹ.
Bánh cái tí chêu rồng mẹ rối từ rối ở trên,
bánh đầy mặc trước bánh đầy này rối ở trên.
Bỏng tay của ta đầy, rối ở trên.
Bánh vỏng tay cái tí, chêu của tôi rất tự,
bánh chiêu của tôi rất tự dụng đại ch'.
Bánh đầy mặc trước bánh đầy mặc.
Bánh đầy mặc là một nâng chó, bánh đầy mặc.
Bánh đầy mặc, tường ra y được sức tự.
Bánh đầy mặc trước đây là hữu ngon lắm.
Nó cũng phải theo chêu
Đi ra từ gấp dý mào tượng nằm
Đi ra
Đúng rồi, đi ra vào bởi vì cái ký phòng cho nè hảm trên
Chánh được trực tượng
Đi lúc từ ra ra nó chí cũng được chêu
Bởi vì cái mình sẽ là hình xa
Đi ra sẽ là hình xa
Thêm cho rần cung này rãi
Cung này là nó dựu xúc xác thì mới
Chẳng là rãi rõ
Chúc cơ gạm, không thì, đặc kênh của tốt
Tặc biệt các em